dexter put out some seriously
mind-blowing episodes in its original 96
episode run but unfortunately they can't
all be good
these are the best and worst rated
episodes of the entire series according
to imdb
the finale of season 4 remains a
shocking hour of television featuring
one of the most tragic deaths in the
entire series season 4 follows dexter's
pursuit of the trinity killer aka arthur
mitchell a church deacon who uses
building sites in ritualized murders
initially law enforcement only believes
him to have committed three murders but
in this episode they discover a fourth
victim in a young boy who is kidnapped
and buried alive under the fresh
concrete of church housing as if that's
not enough dexter's mishandling of
arthur mitchell earlier in the season
leads to trinity murdering dexter's wife
rita leaving baby harrison in her blood
while arthur does end up on dexter's
slab the price isn't worth it this is
also the episode where deb discovers
that dexter is the ice truck killer's
brother which leads to her uncovering
her brother's real identity it's no
wonder this is considered one of the
best episodes of the show
one of the things that makes dexter so
powerful is dexter morgan's ongoing
relationship with his dead father harry
who acts as a ghostly guide in many
episodes
but in nebraska harry is replaced with
dexter's brother brian moser the ice
truck killer who encourages dexter's
worst impulses
it's uncomfortable to watch and not in a
good way dexter discovers the trinity
killer's daughter rebecca killed herself
in a bathtub and his wife sally has been
found bludgeoned to death
assuming that the trinity killer's son
jonah has taken up his father's mantle
dexter drives from florida to nebraska
to confront jonah and kill him but when
he finds out that rebecca killed herself
because of their mother's abuse and
jonah beat his mother to death in
retaliation dexter lets jonah live add
in the convoluted travis marshall plot
the entrance of masuka's creepy dexter
obsessed intern lewis green and deb's
odd relationship drama and this
installment is a true flop
season one of dexter closes with a
string of horrifying reveals and events
in born free deb has been kidnapped by
the ice truck killer brian moser who
also happens to be her fiance under the
name rudy cooper dexter finds out that
brian is his brother and that brian
didn't get adopted alongside him because
harry morgan believed brian would grow
up to be dangerously disturbed by his
memory of their mother's dismemberment
this turns out to be true brian has
spent a great deal of his life
institutionalized before learning to
hide his issues and start a career in
medicine not only is this an incredibly
tense episode as brian offers deb to
dexter on a slab it's also key to
dexter's character development he
chooses his adopted sister over his
blood brother the episode ends with
dexter giving the ice truck killer a
dose of his own medicine
it will surprise absolutely nobody that
the worst episodes of dexter come almost
entirely from the final season in this
entry we get to know zack hamilton a
would-be serial killer who murdered his
father's mistress and plans to kill his
father next
dexter stops him and straps him to his
table but as in nebraska dexter spares
the boy and decides to teach him harry's
code this choice makes no sense in the
show's broader arc since zack is killed
by the brain surgeon just a few episodes
later a little reflection also throws in
a number of clashing narrative arcs
masuka flirts with his daughter deb's
life continues to disintegrate after
murdering laguerta and a new neighbor
named cassie tries and fails to date
dexter
the first episode of season seven is a
doozy that marks the beginning of the
end season six ends with deb discovering
dexter standing over travis marshall's
body about to stab him season seven
picks up in exactly that same moment as
dexter tries to explain away the grisly
tableau deb doesn't believe him but
helps him set a fire to cover up their
involvement in marshall's death anyway
eagle-eyed laguerta has been mildly
suspicious of dexter for some time and
her spidey sense goes haywire when she
finds a blood slide at the scene of the
crime matching the bay harbor butcher's
mo by the end of the episode deb finds
dexter's bloodslides and asks him point
blank
are you a serial killer
yes
this is a vital moment in both deb and
dexter's narrative arcs one that shapes
new tragedies on the way
you'd think that if you were an escaped
and most wanted serial killer with a
well-known face you'd stay away from the
place you were apprehended
if you must go back you'd probably
change your appearance for protection
that's just common sense right well here
lies one of the many problems with dress
code hannah mckay is back and still
wanted by the police yet she's done
absolutely nothing to disguise herself
she doesn't even bother to change her
hair color brave of her to be walking
around miami like that
it's a distractingly stupid detail among
several others that make this convoluted
episode terrible deb gets deep into soap
opera territory as it's clear her boss
is in love with her and acting like a
jealous boyfriend meanwhile deb's ex
quinn is pulling away from his
girlfriend jaime who is also angel's
sister and dexter's nanny this web of
relationships is uncomfortably tangled
and only getting worse
the penultimate episode of season 4 is a
nail-biter as arthur mitchell quietly
discovers who kyle butler actually is a
miami metro pd blood spatter analyst
named dexter morgan suspicious that kyle
might not be who he says he is arthur
seeks out other kyle butlers in town
with murderous results eventually the
trinity killer casually strolls through
miami metro even stopping to admire the
murder board chronicling all his crimes
before coming face to face with dexter
and calling him by his true name hello
[Music]
dexter
morgan this is also the episode when deb
discovers quinn's girlfriend is actually
trinity's estranged daughter and the one
who killed deb's boss and lover special
agent frank lundy it's one of the most
tense episodes of the series and that's
why it's one of the best
the introduction of dr evelyn vogel in
the show's final season undoes much of
what we thought we knew about dexter and
harry morgan we find out that dr vogel
knew harry and helped him develop the
code that shapes dexter making dr vogel
dexter's spiritual mother
the episode goes on to reveal that the
brain surgeon is actually dr vogel's son
who faked his own death as a teenager
and has been living under the name
oliver saxon
when dexter pulls a fast one and tries
to trap the brain surgeon saxon gets
away by the end of the episode we
learned that dr vogel might have been
working with saxon all along a double
cross that doesn't make sense this is
one of the show's weakest episodes when
it should be one of the strongest
john lithgow's tour de force performance
as the trinity killer has several high
notes in this episode in order to figure
out just how such a prolific serial
killer could also be an exceptional
family man dexter stalks arthur mitchell
in the process dexter finds out that
arthur is violent and abusive toward his
family behind closed doors dexter begins
to regret saving arthur when he tries to
kill himself
little does dexter know he'll regret a
whole lot more before the season is up
hungry man features a key thanksgiving
dinner where rita ends up kissing their
neighbor elliot which turns into its own
drama while rita is kissing elliott
dexter is pretending to be kyle butler
at arthur mitchell's house
he gets into a confrontation with arthur
as he tries to protect the mitchells
after arthur breaks his son's finger for
damaging his car it's a harrowing
tightly written episode that hints at
the devastation the season's finale will
bring
the pen ultimate episode of dexter is a
shocker but not in a good way
calling back to the show's popular
trinity killer arc dexter attempts to
double-cross oliver saxon by pretending
to be on his side it almost works but
what does dexter do instead of killing
the man he's been hunting this entire
season
he leaves him alive and calls deb to
arrest him instead
saxon manages to stab clayton the bounty
hunter steal his gun then shoot deb
square in the stomach it's a terrible
way to end the story of deborah morgan
one of the show's most fascinating and
three-dimensional characters
from the very beginning the one person
who suspects dexter morgan is hiding a
terrible secret under his personable
veneer is sergeant james doakes by
episode 9 of season 2 dokes finally
figures it all out dexter morgan is the
bay harbor butcher but like almost
everyone who figures out the truth about
dexter doakes leaves just enough
evidence behind for dexter to spin in
this case dexter's trophy blood slides
in the trunk of doke's car makes room
for miami metro to suspect dokes
while dokes proves to be one of the most
brilliant characters on the show being
the first to id dexter this hour marks
the beginning of doke's untimely end
the tension between dexter and dokes is
extraordinary by this point and the plot
twists are orchestrated for maximum
effect
the vogel and saxon drama continues in
this episode as dr vogel tries to rein
in her psychopathic son the traumas that
turned young daniel vogel into the brain
surgeon are revealed which land oddly
when counterbalanced by dexter planning
to move to argentina with hannah and
harrison things get especially weird
when hannah who still looks exactly the
same as her wanted poster is recognized
by a receptionist at a hospital yes this
increases the tension but in an annoying
way that makes you shake your head
rather than feel nervous for dexter and
his family in the meantime the dab and
quinn drama continues as quinn breaks up
with jaime who verbally assaults deb
right in the middle of miami metro it's
embarrassing to watch
sergeant doakes may have died at the end
of season 2 but his ghost remains very
much present especially once laguerta's
suspicions about dexter start to bear
fruit
dokes died with people believing he was
the bay harbour butcher and laguerta
sees a much desired opportunity to clear
his name when dexter goes after hector
estrada another key player in his
mother's murder dexter concocts an
elaborate plan to frame estrada for
laguerta's murder
in this heart-pounding finale deb
figures out dexter's plan and arrives
just in time for laguerta to wake up
from the sedative she begs deb to kill
dexter or arrest him
but since deb's feelings for dexter have
been revealed to be much more
complicated than a sister's simple love
for her adopted brother she instead
saves dexter and murders innocent
laguerta in cold blood who am i
is this a new beginning
or the beginning of the end
the series finale is consistently listed
as one of the worst endings of all time
instead of being able to say a proper
goodbye to dexter we spend this last
hour watching deb die
after trying to kill deb once more in
the hospital saxon is arrested and
dexter proceeds to kill him in the
police station with a pen dexter sends
hannah off with his son to buenos aires
where he insists he will meet them all
the while a huge hurricane approaches
miami prompting dexter to take deb off
life support and dump her body where he
used to unload his kills before riding
into the storm absolutely none of this
makes sense the last we see of dexter
finds him living as a lumberjack in
oregon it's a dreadful and unsatisfying
ending for everyone's favorite anti-hero
but then again should serial killers get
happy endings check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite tv
shows are coming soon subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one